madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20
heures il faut voir ces images amateurs
pour comprendre l'ampleur du drame qui
s'est joué ce week-end dans un magasin à
pointe à pitre en guadeloupe ces flammes
ont été provoquées par un simple pétard
jeté par un adolescent
trois d'entre eux ont été arrêtés tout à
l'heure alors que les pompes qui ont
découvert aujourd'hui un septième corps
dans les décombres des décombres il ne
reste plus que cela aujourd'hui sur les
lieux de l'explosion d'une canalisation
de gaz à noisy-le-sec lierre nous avons
voulu savoir dans quelles conditions les
habitants de l'immeuble qui s'est
effondré vivait en cette avant veille de
noël dans ce journal vous entendrez le
témoignage poignant de ces familles qui
ont tout perdu
tony le catholique ce sera peut-être le
prochain surnom de l'ex premier ministre
britannique tony blair en vie quand
s'est converti à la religion de sa femme
et de leurs quatre enfants
comme prévu c'était la grande cohue
aujourd'hui dans les magasins les cartes
de crédit ont chauffé comme on dit et
nous verrons que les clients des
dernières minutes sont ceux qui comptent
le moins quand on n'a pas d'idée
mieux vaut avoir des sous il a rejoint
l'autre rivage peut-être celui des
cirque danse était imaginaire l'écrivain
julien gracq c'était un à l'âge de 97
ans il était l'un des plus grands
écrivains français contemporains
le nouveau bilan de l'incendié survenu
dans un magasin de proto pitre en
guadeloupe fait désormais état de sept
morts et d'un blessé grave un septième
corps a été retrouvé sous les décombres
par ailleurs on là après tout à l'heure
la police a procédé à l'arrestation de
trois jeunes gens soupçonnés d'avoir
allumé le pétard à l'origine du drame
philippe rochot ce témoignage filmé par
un amateur sera essentiel dans l'
enquête sur l' incendie du bazar de
produits d'asie qui a fait sept morts
le feu a gagné la rue deux voitures vont
brûler mais dans le magasin tenu par une
famille chinoise
les gens ne peuvent pas sortir car la
110 s'est déclaré à l'entrée sur un étal
de pétards il n'ya même pas d'issue de
secours a été un bois de pétards et puis
après on a vu le feu a pris ça a pris
les étages à une vitesse phénoménale
d'après les témoins ce sont des jeunes
qui ont lancé des pétards sur un étalage
de feu d'artifice qui a pris feu
immédiatement
trois d'entre eux sont d'ailleurs ce
soir en garde à vue photo ne doit pas
être devant le magasin à l'entrée du
magasin sur une table face à ça se fait
par les pompiers ont mis neuf heures
pour éteindre l'incendié car les flammes
leur barrer l'entrée de plus un mur de
béton séparé les deux ailes du magasin
double épaisseur de béton nous a bien
servis ce qu'elle a fait office de coupe
se met elle a également fait à
l'intérieur office de four un four qui
s'alimentait avec les produits
particulièrement inflammable vendus dans
ce bazar et qui n'a laissé aucune chance
aux gens qui étaient à l'intérieur
deux explosions ont réveillé la ville
d'ajaccio ce matin il s'agit de deux
attentats perpétrés en pleine ville à
cinq minutes d'intervalle l'un visait la
trésorerie générale l'autre une caserne
de gendarmerie deux personnes ont été
légèrement blessées ces actions n'ont
pas été revendiquées mais on peut
constater que depuis la fin du procès
dit moi que l'émail les dix jours les
attentats se poursuivre à un rythme
soutenu en corse
triste noël pour les victimes d'une
explosion au gaz samedi à noisy-le-sec
l'immeuble nous vous le disions hier a
pu être évacués à temps mais ses
habitants ont tout perdu 250 personnes
en tout s'apprête à passer un réveillon
sans rien leur foyer leurs affaires
leurs souvenirs ont été ensevelis en
quelques secondes sous un énorme tas de
gravats kermené gier marie cros des
tonnes de gravats et une barre hlm
coupée en deux vingt-quatre heures après
l'explosion
malgré les risques des voisins escalade
les débris il cherche quelque chose
susceptible de remonter le moral des
sinistrés ces photos tout le petit
souvenir qui pourra lui a rappelé en
fait qu'ils habitaient ici que c'est
noël sapins de noël ont tout perdu les
provisions tout perdu un peu dangereux
pour vous ici mais bon sens face à va
pas bien fort pour moi et pour demain ce
matin encore on redoutait que d'autres
poches de gaz n'explose hier par miracle
l'effondrement de deux cages d'escalier
sur quatre étages n'a pas fait de
victime
seuls quelques blessés légers parmi les
pompiers et les policiers
mais 38 familles ne pourront pas passer
noël chez elle certaines ont trouvé
refuge chez des proches ou à l'hôtel
d'autres ont dû dormir dans ce gymnase
comment vous avez passé cette nuit
dehors
en dehors de celui
très mal on a la passion convient
cauchemar qu'ont soyez tout passer
devant moi des souvenirs mais mes bijoux
tissage et plus rien de cyprien
depuis hier tout le monde s'y met vous
avez apporté quoi la chaussure pantalon
vêtements chauds pull tôt tout ce qu'on
peut trouver les bénévoles sont même
dépassés
beaucoup étaient en pyjama au moment de
l'explosion
ils n'ont rien ils ont besoin de cliquer
sur cette voie c'est une amie qui m'a
donné une culotte comme c'est qu'on
venait de naître à l'instant la sagesse
ancienne marson la caresse sur terre
voilà la plus facile juste de quoi se
raccrocher à quelques poteaux sauvé des
flammes
forcément précédemment aussi stressant
pour sa communion solennelle
vous croyez avoir perdu tout ça mais on
a perdu encore naissant est vierge et ma
mère ont trouvé un corps qui avait sauvé
sa en arrache un meilleur filtre en
temps normal un mec
ce que j'espère maintenant c'est que les
gens ne nous laisse pas tomber c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui c'est demain après
m'apprenait demain déjà l'office hlm
leur proposera peut être un vrai
logement les enquêteurs recommence à
peine à déterminer les responsabilités
entre gaz de france et l'entreprise qui
a perforé la canalisation pour les
habitants de la barre stephenson il
faudra du temps pour oublier
cinq ans presque jour pour jour après la
fermeture du centre de sangatte pour
migrants le maire de calais a décidé ce
week-end ouvrir une salle pour
accueillir les candidats au passage en
angleterre
il affirme qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
centre d'accueil permanent mais comment
faire lorsque des centaines de personnes
dorment tous les soirs dans la rue et
dans le froid
il a fait cette nuit dernière la nuit
dernière moins de cinq degrés et loire
vers jean dominique maes de jour comme
de nuit
il marche pour se réchauffer pour ne pas
mourir de froid tous sont des migrants
clandestins déterminés à rejoindre
l'angleterre dans l'espoir d'une
meilleure vie mais toujours bloquée a
calé à la corde avant d'aller à l'école
il fait froid vraiment il ya des gens
qui arrivent ici sans aucune couverture
ni blouson certains sont malades et leur
vie est en danger
on essaie de passer mais des fois on se
fait arrêter par la police française en
essayant de monter dans les calmes unis
et vous essayez souvent tous les soirs
le mythe c'est un repas de noël
alors il y avait foule 350 migrants
servi par des bénévoles
au menu cuisse de poulet pâtes en sauce
et de la chaleur car après un long
voyage les afghans irakiens ou soudanais
sont épuisés certains sont ici depuis
plusieurs mois dans un état de santé
préoccupant
nos amis africains parce qu'il faut pas
du tout habituée à nos températures
donc on a beaucoup qui sont d'ailleurs
on s'en aperçut les trois nuits où ils
ont dormi ils ont vraiment dormi comme
une masse car depuis vendredi soir les
migrants peuvent dormir à l'abri
le maire communiste de calais
réquisitionné une salle de docker sur le
port estimant que le plan grand froid
n'était pas suffisant pour la mairie il
moque des places pour passer la nuit au
chaud en période d'urgence est
exceptionnel il ne faut pas avoir peur
d'ouvrir un local d'urgence est pas un
local permanent c'est pas un nouveau
sangatte que l'on veut ouvrir au
contraire le maire refuse d'ouvrir un
nouveau point de fixation
mais là c'est une situation de crise la
préfecture elle affirme qu'il reste des
places disponibles en centres d'urgence
cette réquisition ne pourra donc pas
duré s'ils se sentent de voeux de venait
à se pérenniser il est bien évident que
l'état réagir et c'est à dire qu'on fera
en sorte que cette activité
disparaissent mais bien évidemment il
faut aussi que le conseil général qui en
est le propriétaire sollicite expulsion
cette nuit encore des migrants tenteront
de traverser la manche ils seraient
entre 300 et 600 attendre leur ticket
coincé à calais les candidats au départ
à orly ouest vont tous pouvoir rejoindre
leur famille attend les personnels au
sol d'air france ont décidé de
transformer la grève en trêve des
confiseurs
le mouvement a donc été suspendue mais
il avait encore aujourd'hui de
nombreuses perturbations
l'ugb aziz un métier ni vencovsky un
face à face qui aura duré quatre jours
passagers d'un côté avions annulés ou
retardés de l'autre bientôt plus qu'un
mauvais souvenir
cet après-midi les tableaux d'affichage
de l'aéroport d'orly reprenait quelques
couleurs de vacances avec des avions à
l'heure mais pas toujours si les avions
décollent avec un peu de retard à la
encore qu'ils nous donnent des
informations on n'a aucune information
on a eu la réponse qu'il y avait une
incertitude
il fallait quand même se présenter et on
a eu la chance de voir ce vol maintenant
on arrive en bas on va être à l'heure
pour les personnes qui viendront nous
chercher puis on pourra prendre
les cadeaux demain à l'heure et c'est
une bonne nouvelle du monde mais plus de
bousculade dans l'aérogare ce soir air
france a finalement pu assurer plus de
80% de ses vols aujourd'hui les agents
au sol en grève qui se battait pour une
revalorisation salariale ont finalement
décidé de suspendre leur mouvement
il a été décidé par les collègues de
suspens non pas d'arrêter la grève pour
pouvoir mieux reprendre et mettre un
ultimatum réel au niveau de la direction
pour ouvrir de réelles négociations avec
de ré les augmentations de salaires et
de conditions de travail
un répit donc pour ces fêtes de fin
d'année avec la menace d'une reprise de
la grève début janvier
air france promet un retour complet à la
normale dès demain matin un chiffre
maintenant combien les français
dépensent t-il pour les cadeaux de noël
il regarde et il s'agit d'une moyenne
par foyer 556 euros dont plus de la
moitié pour les cadeaux c'est plus que
nos voisins allemands et italiens mais
c'est moins que la moyenne de l'union
européenne alors autre constat plus on
fait ses achats tard et plus on est
prêts à délier les cordons de la bourse
moralité quand on n'a pas d'idée mieux
vaut avoir des sous c'est ce qu'ont pu
vérifier cet après midi dans les
magasins caroline thébaux et stéphane
guillemot il est peut être le seul à
prendre le temps de gazouiller avec les
enfants et même de se faire prendre en
photo mais pour tous les autres
le temps presse
c'est toujours à la dernière minute
pourquoi attendre 30 ans ayant alors agi
-20 il faut trouver une idée à tout prix
même en gadgets qui fait oublier les
éthiques
terminus et puis quand on a flashé sur
le cadeau on le prend direct il ya un
côté date limite maquis qui fait que à
partir d'un certain moment on dit que
peu importe le prix car un cadeau quoi
55 euros le bo a tout de même
pourtant les français ont prévu de moins
dépenser cette année pour les cadets
cette famille a donc tout prévu pour
faire des économies
ça vient on a tiré au sort et chaque
camp fait un gros cadeau tout plein de
petits cadeaux noël c'est ici un quart
du chiffre d'affaires annuel et ce
week-end a atteint des sommets face à
250 milles visiteurs jour sur des
journées comme celle d'hier
vraisemblablement comme celle
d'aujourd'hui et des gens qui dépensent
à peu près combien qu'ils vont dépenser
plus de 100 euros en moyenne
sans oublier le dîner du réveillon il
représente 30% du budget des français
un budget en hausse malgré les prix à
cannes ou à augmenter dans le foie gras
les volailles aussi en installant une
plaque de brel à brassens et aussi donc
en économie sur les cadeaux pour plus
que 24 heures après vous pourrez vous
posez et déguster et justement en
parlant de table de noël beaucoup
d'huîtres vont mourir demain sur l'autel
de la tradition rassurez vous elles sont
prêtes en tout cas les producteurs ont
tout fait pour
il joue gros en cette saison reportage
sur le bassin de marennes d'oléron en
charente-maritime
éric pineault aladar écran au petit
matin les premières poches d'huîtres
sont sortis des bassins le calme règne
encore quand soudain une course contre
la montre s'engage noël est là les
commandes aussi la patronne distribuer
encore et encore des bourriches à
remplir à sa brigade féminine
la vrai nom tu leur diras si ça va pas
car ajoute inuits si je ne sais pas
c'est lourd et une journée comme
aujourd'hui pour nous estime et combien
des mourides
c'est plutôt un pouvoir glisser en photo
un point bon ça n'est pas que l'on va
arrêter mais on arrive à sous à sortir
neuf établissements 30 tonnes par jour
elles auront vu deux douzaines de froid
pour gap ça c'est une palette gags dijon
metz paris dont la pièce voisine ce sont
les hommes qui chargent les palettes et
prépare les expéditions cette entreprise
familiale joue gros en cette fin d'année
elle vend 400 tonnes d'huîtres par an
plus de la moitié seront consommés pour
les fêtes de fin d'année ont fait 60 %
de notre volume en deux jours on est en
mono produit 60 % en douze jours non non
on va pas le droit
9-10 ans porte à des camions comme
chaque année en décembre 35 mille tonnes
d'huîtres de marennes oléron vont garnir
une table de réveillon sur deux ce
bassin ostréicole produit à lui seul la
moitié des huîtres françaises
il a réussi le tour de force de mettre
son nom sur toutes les tables et gilbert
ducros fondateur du groupe des pistes
ducrocq est mort hier à l'âge de 79 ans
il est entré dans l'histoire du monde
agroalimentaire français mais aussi dans
celle de la publicité avec cette petite
phrase dont tout le monde se souvient
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
politique britannique un ancien premier
ministre s'est converti au catholicisme
tony blair a quitté l'église anglicane
et a rejoint la religion de son épouse
et de leurs quatre enfants
cela fait longtemps qu'il voulait faire
dit il mais il a attendu de ne plus être
en fonction comme si les pouvoirs
temporels et spirituels n'était pas
encore totalement séparés arnaud
bouteille dominique marault tel à
londres
longtemps il a repoussé cette conversion
jugé personnel élevé dans la foi
anglicane celle de l'église d'angleterre
tony blair devient donc catholique comme
l'étaient déjà à son épouse chérie et
ses quatre enfants
et ce matin à l'heure de la messe devant
la cathédrale de westminster les fidèles
se disent ravis et peu surpris sur une
épreuve tony blair se convertit au
catholicisme souhaitait triet il est
effacé par sa femme je pense que c'est
formidable c'est un homme de grande foi
évidemment il a été un très bon premier
ministre
il pourrait même devenir pape avant de
quitter downing street tony blair avait
été reçue en audience privée par le pape
au vatican
mais en tant que premier ministre il se
gardait bien d'évoquer la religion
refusant même de répondre lorsqu'ils y a
quelques mois un journaliste l'interrogé
sur son éventuelle conversion et vous me
posez cette question tous les ans dans
sa route vers la fois tony blair ne peut
faire oublier ses choix politiques
critiqués par l'église
il y à l'avortement le partenariat civil
pour les homosexuels
et bien sûr la guerre en irak alors ses
opposants ironise à lettonie vous avez
voté contre la parole de l'église quand
vous étiez premier ministre vous avez
changé d'avis vous demander pardon pour
tous à l'église catholique se félicite
de la conversion de tony blair et ses
pratiquants sont désormais plus nombreux
que les anglicans les immigrés
catholique en particulier les polonais
ce conte ici en centaines de milliers
l'europe ne rapproche pas toujours les
peuples exemple en italie depuis
l'entrée de la roumanie dans l'union
beaucoup de roumains ont choisi
d'émigrer là bas c'est même la première
communauté étrangère
résultat la xénophobie à leur égard a
gagné du terrain c'est bien que le
gouvernement italien a décidé
d'autoriser l'expulsion de ceux qui
commettraient des actes graves
correspondance philippe visseyrias
karine guillaume à une semaine d'hôpital
et la peur de sortir dans la rue
ce roumain installé depuis huit ans en
italie se trouvait sur le parking d'un
supermarché
lorsqu'une dizaine d'hommes masqués se
sont jetés sur lui
d'après la police c'était des militants
d'extrême droite j'étais en train de
ranger les courses dans la voiture
j'ai entendu des gens qui criaient je me
suis retourné et j'ai reçu un coup
violent sur la tête
après je me suis évanoui c'est ici qu'a
eu lieu l'agression
t'aurais angela banlieue est de rome
entre ville et campagne
un quartier populaire où s'est installée
en masse la communauté roumaine des
commerces des services publics pas
d'insécurité apparente mais ici
désormais ceux qui n'aiment pas les
étrangers n'hésitent plus à le dire haut
et fort comme ces mères de famille tall
yen à la sortie de l'école
les roannais ont pris le travail des
italiens ils ont amené la prostitution
beaucoup plus que les albanais même moi
je n'étais pas racisme mais je le suis
devenu
chacun chez soi il n'y a que ça à faire
le problème ce sont plutôt les deegan
qui viennent de roumanie ne travaille
pas et sont admises les tziganes
roumains
de plus en plus nombreux en italie
depuis l'entrée de la roumanie dans
l'union européenne en janvier dernier
tous les jours à la gare routière de
rome ils sont des dizaines à faire la
navette avec bucarest une communauté
accusés de vivre de rapine et de
délinquance comme ces adolescents filmé
il ya quelques mois devant la gare de
milan
passé maître dans l'art du pickpocket
une tension alimentée par un fait divers
le meurtre fin octobre d'une italienne
par un roumain d'origine tzigane
argine costica est l'un des porte parole
de cette communauté
désormais placé sous surveillance à tout
moment cette famille peut être expulsé
d'italie
si les autorités estiment qu'elles
représentent un danger pour l'ordre
public ou si elle n'apporte pas la
preuve d'un travail légal ils ne sont
pas d'accord pour rentrer en roumanie
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix la vie pour eux là bas et pire
qu'ici pour l'instant depuis l'entrée en
vigueur du décret gouvernemental début
novembre
360 étrangers ont été expulsés d'italie
c'est un immense manteau blanc qui a
recouvert une bonne partie des états
unis et ça tombe mal car ce week-end 60
millions d'américains un quart de la
population du pays comptait se déplacer
pour les fêtes mais les chutes de neige
sont si importantes que de nombreux axes
ont été fermées pour éviter les
accidents
on compte déjà cinq morts correspondance
alain tien le voit
ce qu'il ya de bien avec les tempêtes de
neige c'est qu'on n'y voit rien et que
tout prend un aspect magique dans une
sorte de halo feutrée à vrai dire les
américains se seraient bien passés de
cette deuxième vague de froid en 10
jours en plein week-end de fête occasion
d'une des plus grandes transhumances de
l'année car à force de conduire à
l'aveuglette dans la tempête voilà ce
qui arrive sortie de route accidents et
carambolages gigantesque 3 quasi
simultanément dans l'oklahoma le kansas
et le texas
plus de 80 véhicules dans ce dernier cas
heureusement ne roule pas vite et l'on
ne déplore pour le moment que cinq morts
dans ces incroyables enchevêtrement de
ferraille
je n'ai jamais rien vu de pareil il faut
dire que le mauvais temps est arrivé
très vite les gens n'ont pas eu le temps
de réagir et il n'y a pas que les
automobilistes qui sont touchés ceux qui
ont choisi l'avion se retrouve bloqué
200 vols annulés
rien qu'à chicago les commerçants
craignent également d'être affectés
difficile d'accéder jusqu'aux centres
commerciaux
même si l'âme consommatrice des
américains l'emportent le plus souvent
beaucoup de gens voulaient venir mais
n'ont pas pu à cause de la neige noël
c'est mardi alors on n'a pas vraiment le
choix
dans le même temps le mississippi était
balayé par des tornades comme on en voit
en principe qu'en avril mai et le
gouverneur de caroline du nord décrété
des mesures d'urgence pour lutter contre
la sécheresse qui a dit qu'il y a
quelque chose de détraqués sur cette
planète neige encore avec une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les amateurs de ski dans
l'un des plus grands domaines du monde
le téléphérique de la vanoise qui relie
la plagne aux arcs ne pourra pas être
mise en service cet hiver
les experts parlent d'anomalies
constatées sur les câbles d'ordinaire ce
téléphérique transport jusqu'à 2000
personnes par heure
virginie fichiers jusqu'à nouvel ordre
le vanoise express restera acquis l'un
des plus gros téléphérique du monde qui
relie la station de la plagne à celle
des arcs a été stoppé pour des raisons
de sécurité il y a qu un jour des
anomalies inquiétantes notamment des
boursouflures et des brins cassez ont
été constatées lors d'un contrôle de ces
câbles porteurs s'impliquent d
des reprises de tension lourde un
travail important sur des câbles
vous avez plus de 150 tonnes de tension
par câble ce qui est difficile de faire
dans l'environnement hivernale résultat
huit mois d'arrêt le temps de fabriquer
et remplaçaient les deux énormes câble
de 75 mm de diamètre un petit supporter
les cabines leur durée de vie est
normalement compris entre 20 et 30 ans
mi-janvier une expertise complète sera
effectué pour tenter de comprendre ce
vieillissement prématuré
un coup dur pour les stations qui
devront se passer cette saison de leurs
atouts technologiques avec des
conditions cette année exceptionnelle
dans les gens donc le client je dirais
va trouver va trouver pour pour le
satisfaire d'une service maximum en
cette fin d'année le vanoise express
n'est pas le seul à être grippée à
courchevel l'un des deux téléphériques
établissant la liaison avec mary bale
fonctionne lui au ralenti une erreur de
manipulation a endommagé une cabine dont
les skieurs seront privés durant ses
vacances de noël
alors la bonne nouvelle quand même vous
l'avez vu c'est que la neige est bien au
rendez-vous dans les alpes et aussi dans
les pyrénées et c'est tant mieux pour
les amateurs de ski hors piste une fois
par an le célèbre pic du midi offre la
virginité de ses pentes aux meilleurs
glisseurs de la région c'était ce
week-end sensations garanties
antoine armand david bres premiers
rayons de soleil sur le pic du midi de
bigorre skieurs et surfeurs s'engage
déjà sur les pentes de ce sommet
pyrénéen une fois par an c'est free
riders les meilleurs du matif se donnent
rendez vous ici pour une descente
d'exception du 100% au freeride c'est
tout simplement d'évoluer en dehors des
pistes
libre à nous de me prendre ses propres
responsabilités de s'informer sur la
neige ne jamais partir seul d'avoir les
équipements de sécurité nécessaires pour
pour faire la descente mais après c'est
que du bonheur passé que de la poudreuse
et le terrain ils le connaissent ils
sont tous nés dans ces vallées barre dès
maintenant de médailles et de titres
mondiaux ils reviennent ce week end
jouer à domicile pour le plaisir
fier d'être pyrénéens et c'est chez moi
parce qu'ils doivent aller plus loin et
vu d'ici c'est vrai que j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut sauter comme
avaler ils ont une grande fougue et une
grande simplicité je pensais comme ça
qu'on peut décrire à oued et les pianos
en quelques minutes ses riders vont
avaler sous leurs spatules l'équivalent
de cinq fois la tour eiffel avec ses
1700 mètres de dénivelé hors piste
le pic du midi n'a pas à rougir des
grands des sandales fine alors c'est
comment le tueur sensation début de
saison en fanfare
on espère que ça va continuer des
saisons qui se suivent et qui disent
toujours un peu plus haut les pyrénées
au rang de vastes terrains du hors-piste
majestueux et sauvage mais attention
tout de même à ne pas trop sortir des
sentiers battus on a appris il ya
quelques minutes qu'un randonneur est
mort dans le massif pyrénéen sur la
commune d'azé il a été emporté par une
coulée de neige
ik à rêver tout simplement de voler
aujourd'hui réchauffement climatique
oblige on rêve d'avion propre et bien un
grand pas vient d'être franchi tout à
l'heure dans les hautes-alpes
regardez une équipe d'ingénieurs
français a réussi pour la première fois
à faire décoller un avion électrique
ce vol expérimental a été autorisé par
la direction générale de l'aviation
civile
il a duré 48 minutes pour l'heure il
s'agit d'un appareil monoplace d'une
envergure de 9 mètres mais ses
concepteurs estiment qu'il pourrait
remplacer à terme les petits aéronefs de
loisirs
on parle souvent des sites et lorsque
les choses vont mal et bien voici un
autre visage de ces quartiers dits
sensibles près de lorient il fallait
bien la solidarité de tous les habitants
pour transformer une tour vouée à la
destruction pour le compte à rebours a
commencé mais comme un calendrier de
l'avent ils ont décidé d'ouvrir chaque
jour une fenêtre sur leur imaginaire
vous allez comprendre
romuald bonnan michel hiver à côté des
gravats d'une tour en démolition un
autre immeuble qui l'été prochain subira
demain
or 14 étages de béton pourtant depuis
quelques mois on refait les peintures
on est parti sur une idée de faire
voyager les gens du quartier qui bien
sûr ne sont pas des gens forcément
fortunés mais bon s'ils ont des envies
de voyage
ici c'est le occasion rêvée car ici
avant l'arrivée des bulldozer prend vie
un curieux musée de laisser m une drôle
de tour de babel où se côtoient
d'anciens locataires des bases un
quartier des curieux un monde de bric et
de broc des cuisines des salles de bains
et des placards qui tout à coup tu
racontes des histoires repères disparu
village d'élite et ce qui a entraîné
comme mots les auroises attentes des 35
ans je suis dans la tour et surtout dit
les mots arrivent avec des mots voter
pour revivre la de douleur et notre
france l'eau dans les étages il ya la
peur des demandeurs d'asile l'angoissent
noire des voeux de l'immeuble placé en
foyer
les aussi de l'humour et l'envi surtout
de reconnaissance de ce quartier
populaire
c'est un quartier qui est un petit peu
décrié mais qui a certainement des
qualités de vie donc on est ouvrir comme
ça un musée infernal où de petites mains
met la dernière touche à un géant de 35
m le calendrier de l'avent terrier
ouvrir les fenêtres pour prendre date
le clin d'oeil de ceux qui souhaite
s'afficher avant de s'effacer
on vit aussi con de diffuser en fait de
la magie dans ces quartiers donc c'est
ça aussi parce qu'elle existe et puis et
puis à une espèce de solidarité dans ces
quartiers comme on imagine pie ix un
respect comme on n'imagine pas et je me
dis bah il faut une direction de créer
une tour détourner un musée ouvert au
public avant de partir en poussière
si vous avez des enfants pas loin de
vous appeler les en un cadeau une image
pour eux d'un scout comme on dit chez
nous elle nous avons pu retrouver la
maison
du père noël dans les neiges du nord
regardez et dans cette blancheur
immaculée elle était bien caché nous
avons surpris le départ du père noël qui
aidé par ses lutins va commencer son
grand voyage à travers les foyers du
monde entier conduit bien sûr par son
traîneau et par ses célèbres rennes
images magnifiques
si vous n'êtes plus assez jeune pour
rêver au moins vous apprécierez le
paysage autre cadeau pour les plus
grands si vous aimez le flamenco
lorsqu'il va suivre va vous plaire à
paris l'une des plus grande danseuse
flamenca au monde incarne une carmen
comme vous ne l'avez jamais vu c'est au
théâtre des champs-elysées
michel mompontet et tristan lebrasse ont
pu assister au spectacle et à ses
coulisses
attention ça décoiffe dans la lumière
quelques heures avant la première
l'heure des ultimes réglages face à la
salle vide est encore obscur
sara baras le temps avance plus vite
qu'un métronome déréglé yaël dans le
tourbillon
un soir d'avant premières
trois heures avant le lever de rideau
c'est l'instant terrible où rien ne
semble prêt jeu demain la star est
partout et le trac qui sert sûrement sa
gorge
il
nokia concernant les terres dans carmen
il y a tellement de choses il faut
régler la chorégraphie la musique les
habits les lumières les vidéos c'est
très lourd quand l'épreuve d'aujourd'hui
sera passée joie qu'ils prennent mois
par les mines
elle pense avoir tout prévu 20 heures le
spectacle commence comme on craque une
allumette
mais tout à coup
alerte incendie les lumières se
rallument évacuations après six minutes
de spectacle
du jamais vu au théâtre des champs
elysées
flottement les nouveaux d'effecteur très
performant de fumée n'ont pas apprécié
le spectacle
45 minutes plus tard est de retour
à la voir danser on se dit que
finalement cette femme de feu a bien de
quoi affoler tous les systèmes anti
incendie du monde
une carmen plein d'étincelles et sara
baras au sommet de la danse espagnole
c'est un de ses spectacles rares dont
l'émotion vous sert longtemps la gorge
cinéma c'est la grande mode en ce moment
les stars du grand écran passe derrière
la caméra
le jeune américain ben affleck n'a pas
résisté il arrive avec son premier film
comme réalisateur gone baby gone et
comme il a le sens de la famille le rôle
principal a été confié à son frère
françois jullien pieds-noirs et sylvain
daube allons rencontrer avec un peu de
difficulté il est vrai le rendez vous
est donné dans un palace parisien avec
ben affleck problème nous n'avons pas le
numéro de sa suite une femme de chambre
va peut-être nous renseigner au mesdames
vous ne savez pas qui est ben affleck et
bien c'est le héros américains de pearl
harbor d'armageddon est le héros à une
époque de jennifer lopez chambre 303 il
ya la fiche de son film
ça doit être là la production nous
interdit de le filmer tant qu'il n'est
pas maquillée et pourtant quel bel homme
diront certaines ou certains 1 m 88 35
ans mais cette fois vous ne le verrez
pas à l'écran il réalise son premier
film et met en scène son petit frère
casey affleck dans une histoire de
disparition
une empreinte au cap journée dans la rue
j'en arrive à la mi journée un détective
privé le frère de ben affleck donc va
enquêter et remuer de vieilles histoires
s'engager pour renforcer manquer
comme le promettre je vous promets
tout se passe à boston c'est la ville
natale des deux frangins ils connaissent
les rues les figurants c'était donc
plutôt rassurant pour un premier film de
tourner en famille il ya des choses que
vous ne pouvez pas obtenir de l'acteur
que vous rencontrer pour la première
fois à melen when you vous avez avec un
frère forcément ça fait des années qu'on
se connaît ça valait le coup de le faire
ensemble
le petit frère n'est plus un débutant
mais il est toujours fasciné par le
grand mon frère a créé une atmosphère
sur le tournage il est super marrant
super professionnel et il s'est fait
respecter par tout le monde mais quand
on n'est pas de la famille c'est bien
plus facile de plaisanter sur le
réalisateur à jour comporte
il est offre horrible et bien ne sait
jamais ce qu'il veut pendant deux heures
la famille affleck nous plonge dans les
bas-fonds de boston et de la pédophilie
étrange l'un pour un réalisateur à la
gueule d'ange et comme chaque dimanche
soir aussi notre box office premier je
suis une légende avec will smith qui
était d'ailleurs notre invité la semaine
dernière dans ce journal
2e alvin et les chipmunks compte
familial qui totalisent plus de 30000
entracte troisième la clé guillaume
canet et marie gillain ont attiré près
de 12000 spectateurs et puis en
quatrième position on retrouve les trois
brigands encore un film pour enfants
alors évidemment ça marche bien en ce
moment dix mille entrées totalisé
c'était l'un des plus grands écrivains
français contemporains l'hommage ce soir
est unanime
julien gracq est décédé à l'âge de 97
ans il détestait les honneurs il adorait
les pays imaginaire il a rejoint hier
l'autre rivage sûrement celui des syrtes
jose dans la pierre
fuyant les caméras et les journalistes
julien gracq malgré le succès garde la
tête froide et un immense recul à
l'égard de lui-même bien un moment où ce
que vous avez fait bomber c'est comme ça
ça vous oblige à prendre quelle posture
ou le changerez pas c'est un fait
vieillissement en 1951 alors qu'il vient
de dénoncer l'incompétence des jurys
littéraires il reçoit le goncourt pour
son livre les rivages de syrte
fidèle à ses idées il refuse le prix
junior de casseroles que j'ai traîné
trop longtemps parce que les jours
l'homme qu'a refusé le prêt go sam a
confirmé tout à fait dans le détail les
prix littéraires et de leurs valises et
julien gracq et la main qui ne transige
pas il est parfaitement fidèle à ses
principes à ses valeurs à ses idées ça
c'est pour moi c'est une question de
caractère
c'est une question de morale il avait un
vide moral de ce qu'il était et de ce
côté-là pas en écrivant à la société ici
et n'eut jamais publié en poche
julien gracq est l'un des rares
écrivains à être entré de son vivant
dans la prestigieuse pléiade
hormis dans cette collection pour lire
du grac il faut le mériter
gracq a toujours été publié chez josé
corti qui a joué la spécialité de faire
des livres non mais si côté ce qui veut
dire que le livre n'est pas coupé donc
vous ne pouvez pas lire gracq si vous
n'avez pas une première car l artiste il
te docteur dans la maison du maine et
loire où il est né julien gracq recevait
encore de temps à autre quelques
lecteurs ou écrivains triés sur le volet
l'agrégée d'histoire et de géographie
les 19 ouvrages une oeuvre classique
poétique sans concession
et puis l'autre deuil aujourd'hui
c'était l'un de nos principaux titres
dans ce journal je vous le rappelle il
concerne la guadeloupe
un septième mort a été retrouvé sous les
décombres du magasin incendié à pointe à
pitre
ces images amateurs montrent la violence
des flammes et la vitesse à laquelle
elles se sont propagées après qu'un
pétard a été lancée par des adolescents
trois jeunes gens d'ailleurs été arrêté
tout à l'heure ils ont entre 15 et 18
ans c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant la météo
laurent romejko à 20h50 ne manquez pas
les aventures d'harry potter dans la
chambre des secrets
demain pour l'information vous
retrouverez élise lucet à 13h et
françoise laborde à 20 heures et puis en
ce qui nous concerne mais on se retrouve
le week-end prochain donc avec un peu
d'avancé vous souhaite un joyeux joyeux
noël et une excellente soirée sur france
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
votre soirée